j'accueille maintenant aïcha el wafi
bonsoir madame un bonsoir bienvenue
parmi nous alors vous êtes la mère de
zacarias moussaoui qui détient aux usa
depuis août 2001 et qui d'après la
justice américaine aurait dû être le 20e
pirate de l'air dans l'attentât du world
trade center et bonne nouvelle on a reçu
cette semaine on a reçu jeudi une
dépêche afp qui dit l'accusation ne
pourra pas demander la peine de mort je
crois que pour vous c'est vraiment
quelque chose
d'exceptionnel j'imagine un juge
américain a interdit jeudi à
l'accusation de demander la peine de
mort contre le français zacarias
moussaoui
inculpé par la justice américaine de
complicité dans les attentats du 11
septembre 2001 voilà on est au repos
on va reprendre les choses 2 0
le 13 septembre 2001 à 7h30 êtes dans
votre lit vous êtes réveillé par votre
fils qui vous dit réveille-toi allume la
télé il ya zacharias ils disent qu'ils
l'ont arrêté parce que c'est un
terroriste pour vous c'est le début du
cauchemar j'ai dit c'est pas vrai
question j'allume la télé y rien et
j'attends un à 8h30 il y a il ya cette
lecture de dépêches tous les matins et
c'est là où j'avais ma carrière moi
je ne reconnais pas mon fils parce que
j'ai jamais vu comme ça vous voyez la
photo qui a c'est pas possible c'est pas
mon fils et j'attend jusqu'à
9 heures parce que je sais que la dst
une malice et des coordonnées au chaos
quoi vous la destine je vais appeler un
petit peu avant déjà et il avait des
doutes un peu sur ce qu'ils aiment sur
ce qu'ils faisaient pas quoi oui la
destinée et venez me voir la première
fois c'était au
début de
2001 me demandant si je connais ou aider
mon fils zacharias judy non et je lui
expliqué que 90 97 il est venu me voir
en me demandant pardon pour tout qu'est
ce qui s'est passé et on a gardé le
contact à peu près je pense six mois il
me téléphonait pratiquement deux fois
par semaine et elle m'a demandé d'aller
le voir donc j'ai pas voulu aller le
voir parce qu'il m'a dit qu'il va nous
réserver une chambre à l'hôtel je lui
dis que je n'ai rien à faire si je viens
pas si je ne suis pas dit que la
victoire toi qui viens il ya un amuser
les grandes elle me dit moi je suis dans
un foyer et que je ne peux pas tu as
menée dans un foyer où il ya collusion
et donc je sais pas aller
alors zacharias donc on vous le dit
après est présumé être le 20e pirate
dans les attentats du world trade center
six chefs d'inculpation dont 4 mérite la
peine de mort est là pour sauver une
lettre quelques jours après de lui qui
vous dis maman j'ai rien fait je suis
innocent effectivement c'est là où le
cac est compliqué zacharias a été arrêté
en août pour un problème de visa
expirait et et le 11 septembre quand ont
lieu les attentats il a en prison depuis
déjà un mois
voilà donc ça c'est une quelque chose
qui le disculpe ah oui mais en même
temps quand il a été arrêté il
s'entraîner au maniement des boeing et
il disait qu'il était plus intéressé par
le dise à son professeur de de pilotage
qui étaient plus intéressés par les
décollages que par les atterrissages non
ça n'existe pas
je vous le dis je vous écoute
par les avocats qu'ils ont le dossier en
main ils ont rectifié ça en verlan
les médias américains
la seule chose pourquoi ils l'ont arrêté
c'est qu'ils ont senti que ilité palais
et
il y avait un
moment qui est que prenez ces cours de
pilotage
la personne qui lui donne des cours et
lui demande qu'est ce que vous faites
pour le ramadan et là mon fils est ici
ticket est il
il a trouvé ça c'était bizarre et le
monsieur qui lui donne des cours du
dîner il pense pourquoi il était
complètement tout à fait bizarre et
c'est ça qu'il attirait l'attention de
satom pour avertir l'ifria voilà alors
en janvier 2002 vous fait un premier
voyage aux etats-unis vous voyez pas
zacharias car le fbi elle devait
enregistrer la conversation
les avocats vous dise n'y allez pas
parce que c'est un violation des droits
de la défense vous allez aux états unis
sans le rencontrer le 22 avril donc 2002
zacharias comparaît devant une cour en
virginie alors la cti parce qu'il nie sa
participation effectivement vous avez
aux attentats du 11 septembre qui était
en prison mais il reconnaît être un
guerrier de l'islam il appelle à la
destruction du peuple juif et des usa et
remet sa vie entre les mains d'al là il
dit je suis un esclave dallas enfin bon
ils se présentent comme l'archétype du
terroriste admirateur de ben laden est
il dit si un jour je suis remis en
liberté je passerai ma vie à tuer des
américains donc là même s'il n'avait pas
été mêlé aux attentats du 11 septembre
pour les gens devant lesquels il
comparaît il est coupable d'une certaine
façon oui je comprends que c'est dit des
mots très très grave mais il faut avoir
les conditions pendant quand même 11
mois aux élites et donc moi je pense et
je l' ai vu c'est un nom qu'il était
bliss est émis et pour moi comme je
connais zachary fier comme il est
touché dans son honneur dans son que
c'est une femme qui levait le fouiller
quand il a eu l'occasion de parler il a
dit que le pire des choses qu'il peut
dire qu'il va procéder à dix heures par
énervement voire et nerveux ma part à
vengeance par des repères du mal de
l'autre côté par un ils l'ont fait du
mal si tu ne gardes cas même si chez qui
lui en a amené les amériques alors là
ils récusent ses avocats et il annonce
vouloir se défendre tout seul alors vous
y allez et le 12 juillet 0,2 donc il
plaide coupable sans doute il a trouvé
un accord avec l'accusation pour
échapper à la mort vous pensez qu'il a
été manipulé au moment où il a plaidé
coupable
c'est à dire que john walker
le même à côté de lui ce qu'il peut dire
voilà excusez moi madame je vais
expliquer nos amis téléspectateurs
johnnie walker c'est le taliban
américain les services fédéraux l'ont
mis à côté de zacharias est donc à ce
moment là et lui d'ailleurs ce johnny
walker a obtenu une remise de peine en
plaidant coupable et ont pensé qu'ils
l'ont mis là pour convaincre
zacharias de plaider coupable
donc mon fils est là qu plaider coupable
est juste bon moment que dieu nous a car
il a dû plaider coupable et après il
s'est rétracté d'ailleurs une semaine
plus tard oui il ya il a arrêté de
plaider coupable alors ensuite il a
entrepris de prouver son innocence en
demandant l'audition de responsables
d'al-qaïda détenus par l'armée
américaine en disant écoutez convoqué
l'est ils vous diront que je suis pas
mêlé à tout ça alors le juge était ok
mais le gouvernement américain a dit non
on se retrouvait dans un ce qu'on
appelle un trou noir juridique avec une
solution on a parlé de ce tribunal
militaire est là s'ils passent devant un
tribunal militaire
bien sûr qu'il est condamné et c'est là
qui est arrivé cette dépêche donc
l'accusation ne pourra pas demander la
peine de mort contre acariès moussaoui
pour vous il est innocent
pour moi il ne te sens bien sûr pour la
pente à
ça c'est sûr et comme c'est lui même qui
l'a connaît qui lie part mais le qaïda
et par les sages c'est lui qui le sait
mieux que moi moi je peux vous dire que
pour l'attentât du 11 septembre ça y'a
pas de doute il n'a rien à voir ouais
alors est-ce que vous pensez que cette
décision de la justice américaine est dû
à une intervention du gouvernement
français
pas du tout ouais je pense que là la
france
est là devoir envers mon fils mon fils
il est né en france citoyens français et
donc il faut kirya j'ai la france comme
comment citoyen français pour monfils si
mon fils et il est abandonné bord de
parole le gouvernement français les
américains ils sont capables de faire
n'importe quoi avec mon fils jack vous
pensez quoi de cette affaire dont je me
dire que je pense que c'est ce sentiment
aussi de madame
avec le terrorisme nous devons avoir
aucune aucune complaisance donc nous
avons tous été
révulsée révolté par le ceo septembre et
par d'autres actes terroristes
ça c'est une chose est sûre laquelle il
faut être clair et net
deuxièmement le terrorisme la lutte
contre le terrorisme ne peut pas
justifier les atteintes aux droits de
l'homme qui sont habituellement commises
par le gouvernement américain
sans doute à l'égard de votre fils mais
aussi à l'égard de toute une série
personnes aujourd'hui je pense notamment
à ceux qui sont aujourd'hui à guantanamo
qui ont été capturés en afghanistan
voici deux ans sans aucune protection
sans aucune transparence sur leur
situation et donc il ya là manifestement
une atteinte aux droits de l'homme et la
procédure de jugement équitable et les
etats unis aujourd'hui se rendent
coupables d'actes contraires disons au
droit international ajoutons à cela que
dans l'intervalle n'ya eu l'intervention
en irak était une invention elle même
illégale illégitime
ça c'est un problème plus général
aujourd'hui le la mairie je trouve dans
un véritable fiasco en irak mais pour
revenir à votre fille je crois que le le
devoir du gouvernement français qu'il
doit accomplir est un devoir de
protection diplomatique
et j'imagine que le consul washington
lui a rendu visite
parce que je suis allé le voir le du
mandant comme mon fils quand il est ils
l'ont arrêtée il y avait personne du
gouvernement français qu'il est parti
voir mon fils de quel état ou de quelles
conditions il était mon fils c'est vous
même qui avait alerté les autorités j'ai
demandé à la dst et au quai d'orsay pour
mon fils alors zacharias est en prison
sous un régime très particulier qui
s'appelle le régime supermax si le plus
sévère dans les prisons américaines il a
une cellule qui fait 6 mètres carrés la
lumière était allumée jour et nuit et il
est réveillé toutes les demi-heures n'y
a pas de fenêtre il a droit à rien ouais
je peux vous dire même si plus que
superman
superman saison certains droits ouais
lui il a droit à rien mais si votre fils
est imaginé gossip soit coupable
imaginez c'est un instant le fait qu'il
se soit fait arrêter quelque part c'est
lui a sauvé la vie parce que s'il avait
été dans l'avion je serais plus là
aujourd'hui donc en tant que maire se
séparent si monfils ya vie d'épreuves
conquois élite emilie de cet attentat
crois moi que je n'aurai pas de la force
devrait de dire un mot parce que d'avoir
tant de morts 3000 morts je ne peux pas
parler ce n'est pas possible c'est
incroyable mais je peux pas j'ai je veux
me mettre dans un coin à pleurer pour
monfils mr jp pas le défendre comme je
fais maintenant mais à partir du moment
que mon fils n'est pas 1000 et de sa
justice mme qu'il a droit de d'avoir un
procès équitable mais une raison de plus
que ce qu'il m'a fait peur avec les
américains quand j'ai vu qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait en irak ils ont respecté
aucun droit de personnes aucune loi
entre nationaux et j'ai pensé la monf
ici n'est en danger mon fils est une
goutte d'eau dans le sillon six ont pas
respecté tout un peuple comment ils me
respectent et mon fils et toutes les
bombes qui sont tombées à nérac je me
sentais est tombé sur moi et vous pouvez
demander mon docteur les prétendants de
médicaments j'ai arrêté de regarder la
télé je me sentais humiliée aussi parce
que c'est pas possible un peu plus fort
le plus grand géant du monde entier
tapie sera un peuple
comme ça moi j'ai dit mais mon fils il
est foutu et je pense quand même qu'il
les français ils vont pas laisser
monfils tombé sur tout le gouvernement
j'étais très fier d'être avoir
nationalité française quand le
gouvernement français il a tenu tête
pour ça que cette guerre mais les choses
ont changé il ya beaucoup de choses en
jeu je le comprends mais c'est pas une
raison d'un de laisser mon fils et à un
sacrifice pour les américains
eh bien
à